EVERY TIME YOU GET A FALSE
PROMISE OF SECURITY, YOU GIVE UP
YOUR FREEDOMS.
HERE WITH MORE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR LAWRENCE JONES.
LAWRENCE, I GOT A LOT OF
REACTION.
THAT WAS A HEARTBREAKING
INTERVIEW LAST NIGHT.
I THOUGHT ABOUT IT ALL NIGHT AND
ALL DAY TODAY.
PLEASE COME IF YOU TALK TO THAT
FAMILY AGAIN, PLEASE SEND OUR
PRAYERS AND OUR LOVE AND OUR
SUPPORT.
I DON’T KNOW HOW YOU RECOVERED
FROM THAT.
>> YEAH, BROTHER, IT WAS A TOUGH
INTERVIEW.
GOOD EVENING, SEAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME.
YESTERDAY WHEN WE BROUGHT THAT
HEARTBREAKING INTERVIEW THAT THE
SHOOTINGS HAD INCREASED TO 130%.
BASED ON THE INFORMATION I’M
GETTING FOR MY SOURCES AND THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT, SHOOTINGS
HAVE INCREASED TO 161%.
LAST NIGHT WAS A BLOODBATH.
18 PEOPLE WERE SHOCKED.
A 17-YEAR-OLD IS NOW DEAD.
I WENT TO EAST HARLEM TO TALK TO
THE RESIDENCE TO GET THEIR VOICE
AND HERE’S WHAT THEY HAD TO SAY.
WATCH.
>> MOTHER, DO YOU FEEL SAFE?
>> NO, NO.
THAT’S WHY I’VE GOT MY GUN
LICENSE.
>> THE POLICE.
EVERYBODY, IT’S LIKE, IT’S LIKE
YOU’RE SAYING I’VE GOT TO STAND
OUT HERE.
>> DO YOU THINK IT WAS A BAD
MOVE?
>> I FEEL BAD.
THEY ARE KILLING INNOCENT
PEOPLE.
>> DO YOU FEEL SAFE IN THE
COMMUNITY?
>> NOT AT ALL.
>> THEY GOT A BILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE POLICE AND IT LOOKS
LIKE CRIME IS GOING UP RIGHT
NOW.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE THAT’S THE
SOLUTION?
>> I THINK WHAT’S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW IS THE PEOPLE ARE
POLICING THEMSELVES.
SEAN, IT’S NOT JUST THE
RESIDENTS OF NEW YORK THAT ARE
SAYING THIS, THE PPA
PRESIDENT PAT LYNCH SAYS THAT
THE BLAME LIES WITH
BILL de BLASIO, THE MAYOR OF
NEW YORK.
HE LIVES IN THIS HOUSE RIGHT
BEHIND ME.
HE SAYS IT WAS THE RESPONSE TO
CUTTING $1 BILLION AS , WELL,
AS GETTING RID OF THE ANTI-CRIME
UNIT.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT HE HAD TO
SAY.
>> 18 PEOPLE WERE SHOT LAST
NIGHT.
WHY?
>> BECAUSE THE CITY HAS GIVEN
OUR STREETS BACK.
OUR CITY COUNCIL, OUR MAYOR’S
OFFICE, THE STATE LEGISLATURE
HAVE HANDCUFFED POLICE OFFICERS
AND GIVEN THE STREET BACK TO THE
CRIMINALS.
REMEMBER JUST A FEW SHORT YEARS
AGO THE CITY WAS OUT OF CONTROL.
POLICE OFFICERS LITERALLY TOOK
OUR STREET CORNERS BACK BLOCK BY
BLOCK BECAUSE OUR LEADERSHIP
ASKED US TO PURELY PRESENTED THE
NEIGHBORHOODS BACK TO THE GOOD,
HARDWORKING PEOPLE THAT WERE IN
THEM.
THIS ADMINISTRATION DECIDED
THAT’S NOT GOOD.
THEY DEMONIZE POLICE OFFICERS,
CHANGE THE RULES FOR IT’S
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO OUR JOB IN THE
CRIMINALS TAKE ADVANTAGE.
WHEN A CRIMINAL HEARS FROM
CITY HALL, THERE’S GOING TO BE A
SOFT TOUCH ON CRIME.
THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THAT
MEANS.
IT’S A SMORGASBORD ON THE
STREETS AND WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT AND THEY HAVE.
WE HAVE CHILDREN BEING SHOT ON
THE STREETS.
HOW TERRIBLE CAN THAT BE?
>> A 1-YEAR-OLD WAS KILLED.
>> A 1-YEAR-OLD ON TOP OF A
14-YEAR-OLD, A 15-YEAR-OLD, OUR
ASPIRING BASKETBALL PLAYER IN
THE BRONX WAS GOING TO ANNOUNCE
TO HIS MOTHER WHAT COLLEGE HE
CHOSE TO GO TO.
BEFORE HE CAN DO THAT, HE WAS
GUNNED DOWN.
IT’S HAPPENING SO OFTEN NOW.
WE ARE FORGETTING THE TRAGEDIES
THAT HAPPEN BEFORE THAT.
WE ARE WAKING UP IN THE MORNING
AND SAYING HOW MANY LAST NIGHT?
IT’S CRAZY.
>> IS THE MAYOR RESPONSIBLE
QUESTION OR TELL ME ABOUT HIM
CUTTING A BILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT AND THE
IMPACT IT’S GOING TO HAVE ON THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
IT’S NOT JUST ONE THING BUT
SAYING THAT WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
A BILLION DOLLARS FROM YOUR
BUDGET BECAUSE THERE WAS A
SLOGAN ON THE SIGN ADAM MARCH.
AND THEN THE MAYOR SAYS WE ARE
GOING TO DO IT.
>> DEFUND THE POLICE.
AS A PERSON THAT HAS PROTESTED
IN MY LIFE, PROTESTING THE
FAIRNESS OF POLICE OFFICERS AND
I HAVE EVEN MARCHED, I LIKE IT
BECAUSE YOU SAY DEFUND THE
POLICE.
THE DEFINITION CAN MEAN
SOMETHING TO YOU IN SOMETHING
DIFFERENT TO ME SO THEY START
YELLING IT AND THEN YOU HAVE THE
COWARDICE OF OUR CITY COUNCIL
AND THE MAYOR’S OFFICE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE PROTESTERS
WANT.
THEY’RE NOT GOING TO STOP AT A
BILLION DOLLARS.
THEY DON’T WANT POLICE OFFICERS
ON OUR STREETS.
THEY DON’T WANT THEM TAKING THE
GUNS OUT OF PERPS BELTS.
WHAT’S NEXT?
WHAT’S THE NEXT SLOGAN WE ARE
GOING TO CHASE?
>> IS THERE ANY HOPE OF TAKING
THE CITY BACK?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, I AM A GUY WHO
ALWAYS SEES THE LIGHT AT THE END
OF THE TUNNEL BUT I’LL BE HONEST
I’M HAVING A HARD TIME EVEN
SEEING THE TUNNEL.
>> SEAN, HE ALSO SAID IN THE
INTERVIEW THAT HE’S ALL FOR
GETTING RID OF ALL THE BAD
APPLES THAT ARE IN THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
HE DOESN’T WANT THEM PART OF THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT BY THE WAY
THAT THE MAYOR IS HANDLING IT IS